welcome to episode 80 of the michaela
peterson podcast
this is an absolutely insane episode
it features muhammadu old salahi who
spent
14 years in guantanamo bay without being
charged
his story was made into a hollywood
movie called the mauritanian that was
released earlier this year
starring benedict cumberbatch and jodie
foster
if you want an episode that'll instantly
stop you from feeling sorry for yourself
this is it this guy has been through
absolute hell
i've recommended his story to a number
of my podcasting friends to share it
because this is a story that absolutely
needs to be heard
it's completely unacceptable that the
u.s government okayed the treatment of
muhammadu
like this it's embarrassing to say the
absolute least
it's a human rights travesty we spoke
about the series of unfortunate events
that resulted in his imprisonment
and torture for 14 years at guantanamo
bay
as an innocent man he's unbelievably
positive for being through such horrors
so we talked about how he managed to
stay sane and positive
we talked about recovering from trauma
and more remember to hit subscribe if
you enjoy this content
or at least learn something i can't
thank muhammadu enough for sharing his
story
it's not an easy one to share this
episode is brought to you by
self-authoring
i chose self-authoring because muhammadu
wrote his memoir
and self-authoring helps you write it
was developed by my dad over the last 30
years with help from two other phds at
mcgill and harvard
the self-authoring suite is a series of
online writing programs that
collectively help you explore your past
present and future the self-authoring
modules allow you to write out your past
i do recommend writing about trauma at
least a year after it's over so you
don't re-traumatize yourself all over
again
the present authoring program has two
modules the first helps you
understand and rectify your personality
faults it's a bit brutal
the second helps you understand and
develop your personality virtues
the future authoring program helps you
envision a meaningful healthy and
productive future
three to five years down the road and to
develop a detailed implementable plan to
make that future a reality
use code mp to get 10 off at self
authoring.com
these past present and future modules
help you get organized which is really
important
in order to achieve success in your life
selfauthoring.comcodemp
here's the episode thanks to ahmed for
sending me the recommendation to
interview this guy
and good luck to you folks watching the
episode
[Music]
welcome to my podcast thank you for
having me mikhaila
so i'm in dubai and one of my friends
here
alerted me to your story which i wasn't
familiar with
and it is quite a story that i
wouldn't wish on anybody but it's quite
a story
so could we just start off with
you giving a brief background about
you know what happened to you um i'll
let you take it from here for the
beginning
absolutely michaela
i fell on the radar of the united states
intelligence
because of a very logical event
i received a phone call from my cousin
who then lived in the sudan
and he was a close friend to the late
osama bin laden and it was just a family
call
he called me and his father was
in the hospital he was sick and he asked
me to hire some money
and i told him of course i would help
him wire the money
to pay the bills of the hospital
where his father was held
and so that
phone belonged to actually to the latest
and
laden and then every move i did
everything i did
every gesture i did was interpreted
in a very cynical and evil way
and the
german intelligence investigated me
because then i was living in
germany that was late 99
they came to our imam imam that is the
leader of the community
where i live they showed him my picture
and he looked at it and he was laughing
he later
on told me he said yeah i know this guy
he very well
and what's the deal and they said
he is he is wanted by his
or a person of interest for a very
powerful country
and he said but this guy wouldn't hurt a
fly
i know i mean they said we think you're
right but
we just want to tell you that when the
imam told me the story i freaked out
and i just wanted to leave germany yeah
and and i
decided to go to move to canada
i think that's your native country
because
back then my friend who studied with me
was
five years older than me he also studied
in germany and he told me that people
like me are very
wanted in canada because i studied
microelectronics telecommunication
and i applied and i i received this
landed immigrant status and i moved to
canada
it's like okay now all the troubles are
going to go away
no one knows me i'm going to start a new
life and we say in this part of the
world
falling from a cliff into a well
as like you know as luck had it
i went to this mosque in montreal called
sunnah and around the same time like i
think
about three weeks after my arrival a
person by the name of
ahmed rasam tried to cross
the canadian-american border and hurt
innocent people in the united states of
america
and they said that he attended the same
mosque
as i did and to americans the equation
was complete
i was a guy receiving a call from my
cousin
who is a friend of ubl from the phone of
ubm
now i'm moving to canada and a few weeks
after my arrival
a person who went to the same mosque as
i did trying to cross to canada and they
called me as the mastermind
of the millennium plot even though i
don't know this guy
i never met him i never heard his name
and from there my life went to
hell everything everything was really
bad
of course canadian couldn't arrest him
because canada is a country
ruled by law but they conspired with the
united states of america
and my country to lure me away from
canada
in a place where there is no law and
kidnapped me
that exactly what happened the
mauritanian spoke to my mother and asked
her to call me back home
because she was sick and i went because
when my mother
called me i go to my mother you know
and i was kidnapped yeah i was kidnapped
in dakar
and i was taken in a special plane in
mauritania
mauritania did investigation they
couldn't find any evidence linking me to
anything
and they the american asked them not to
let me leave the country after a few
weeks of my release
and the 911 had the catastrophe that had
so many
innocent people losing their life from
all religions
from all backgrounds and
america i was just blinded with anger
and i was rendered to jordan for eight
months then to afghanistan
then to guantanamo bay where i was
subjected
to these special measures they called
enhanced interrogation technique a
euphemism for torture
i was sexually assaulted on many
occasions
i was beaten my they broke my ribs
i was sleep deprived for
many many months and so on and so forth
i'm so grateful that i'm back home after
16 years of imprisonment
and i decided to forgive every single
person because
i believe in peace and i believe
in co-existence cohabitation of
people of all background and to be
honest to you
michaela i have no use for anyone
suffering
okay well your story
is i mean it sounds like a movie right
it doesn't sound like something that it
sounds like it would be a movie and i
know
that they turned it into a movie
recently
and i want to talk a bit about that but
mostly what i wanted to talk about was
how you managed to survive like
how you how how you were so resilient
um a lot of the podcasts i do
focus on people who are really ill
and so resiliency is something that i'd
like to talk about and
you went through absolute like i mean i
can't imagine it unimaginable hell
and you've like you just said you've
managed to forgive everybody which is
that
alone is incredible because
um i say most people who go through
hardships
are resentful and angry um even if
that's not necessarily good for them
it's hard to not be angry so
how did you like how did you manage okay
one thing did you think you were ever
going to be able to get out
uh uh first i i want to second
everything you said
everything you said uh it's really it's
really
right no i resigned to my
faith on many occasions when they came
to me
one day richard zuli is a cop
from chicago and he took over my torture
and this is not something against
muslims or
arabs or african he he was involved in
torturing
american people too so she's
like his job when he came to me and he
told me
he's going to arrest my mother and put
her in a
military prison with
only men you know i
at that point i know i had nothing to
lose
there is no more no more anything i i
was like i'm ready
i'm ready i can tell you everything you
want
i can sign every confession you chose
you know because the last thing i saw
from my mother
is when the police came to my home
and they took me and i could see her in
the rearview
mirror as i pulled away she was praying
frantically you know this
tasby has spray beads and
she was like praying frantically and i
turned right
and then she disappeared forever i never
ever get to see my mother again and
she died in pain and suffering and i
never
i never actually michaela i never
understood the magnitude of her pain
you know i was young i didn't care but
now i have my son
ahmed and i can never imagine
that someone would come to me and take
away my
son and this is not canada or the u.s or
a free country where they come to say
you know what we arrest your son because
of
a b and c he was involved in drugs he
did this
someone would understand there is pain
but someone would understand
and but this is someone who say i'm
taking your son and i'm not
explaining to you anything and i don't
owe you any explanation
then i told him i signed everything. and
then
sergeant shelley told me to sign that
i was planning to attack cn tower
i never heard before that of cn tao
later on i was told it was in i think
toronto
because i lived in montreal and i told
him no problem
and i signed a complete false confession
and i put my signature and i was
they said they will give me a death
penalty
as you saw in the movie and
this is like horrible but let me go back
to your question of
resilience you know michaela
we always need to ask ourselves what
does matter most in life
i spent eight months in
the prison of darkness in jordan when i
was rendered to jordan
i didn't know days nights i was
in a basement most of the time not all
the time but most of the time
and i lost count of days
they took me from jordan
to the airport i was blindfolded i
couldn't see i couldn't hear
your mouth and they start to
cut open my clothes scissors first time
you know i this is technique i don't
know
about and then they stripped me naked
then they put me in diapers
i knew then that my life
will change forever i picture myself
you know in one of these violent
american prisons
dying you know no one care about me
no one will ever hear about me in my
whole life
in a split of second run through my head
my whole life what i regretted
most michaela is any
bad words i told anyone any bad comments
i told anyone any bad gesture
i told anyone that what i regretted
i never regretted not having money i
never regret that i'd have a million
dollar in my account
i never agreed that i didn't marry that
very hard chick
i met at in college or anything
none of that mattered what mattered
to me was how good i was to people
and i took it upon myself if allah
if god ever gives me a chance
to live again i will be nice
to people that i will be nice and
michaela this is not easy to be nice
because people push you not to be nice
you know but it pays off to be nice to
people
and i'm trying my hardest and i'm not
saying i'm
successful all the time but this is uh
this is uh how do you call it in english
this is uh yeah
this is something i took upon myself
basically
and i'm going to to do my best to be
nice to people to forgive
everyone and to help as much as i could
and i don't care about your background i
don't care about
your religion i don't care about the
color of your skin
or your political color or
with whom your heart beats the most yeah
okay well okay next
next question i guess uh how are you
able to
talk about these experiences now
like how is it i mean people go through
less and they have
ptsd and they're not able to
you know talk about these experiences or
write about them
um so how are you able to
talk about these how did you manage to i
guess
get through it in your brain
michaela the hardest part was
sexual assault and
i'm saying this i'm admitting something
that i'm ashamed of
that whenever i heard when i was young
you know whenever i heard about sexual
assault
i would i would like so what
if someone make an advance you know on
me so what
i go for it and
this is very horrific thing to say
and it's a very horrible thing it's very
ignorant
because sexual assault is something that
is
very scary very painful
very unpleasant you know someone who
pushes themselves on you
without your consent without you
uh calling them that's the the worst
experience
i experienced in my life and i'm a man
and i'm aware that sexual assault
usually
victims are women unfortunately
and it's like allah is showing me
muhammad you're wrong
you're just like anyone else and
if this you know those people who push
themselves and it's also the shame in my
culture i know you're
aware of our culture and so like
we it's very easy to shame us with
sexuality
and so and everything is in the dark and
we don't
even get educated as much as
people in the west like in canada or of
the united states of america
and in my first interview
i literally touched upon it and then my
family came to me said muhammad
what are you talking about you cannot
talk about this now
and i said no i will talk about it
because
there are so many people who were
assaulted
and who chose not to speak and i'm going
to speak about this and i'm going to go
through the pain
and bite the bullet i'm sharing my story
with you
because muhammad gul could not share his
story with you
he died in the cold room i described in
my book
he died of hypothermia i shared my story
because
dali war could not share his story with
you
because he died of beating when the
guard beat him to death
those are not theory those are recorded
cases that the united states government
admits to and we don't know about the
our cases
and and this need to stop this exception
that
african and middle eastern people don't
deserve
dignity don't deserve human rights need
to stop
we want the same rights as
you me kayla enjoy in canada we want the
same rights as
american people enjoy we want the same
right as western people
enjoy we want freedom we want democracy
we want to be friend to everyone and
open to everyone
and we want to be just part of the free
world
okay do you do you think the people who
are working as guards in those types of
jails
is there something wrong with them like
are they bad people
i don't understand how somebody could
have a job as somebody
who hurts somebody else
no i don't think they're bad people
michaela
history always taught us this mob
mentality so people
forget who they are people are capable
of
of doing bad things you know whether
they're muslims
where they're christians why black asian
we know this throughout history and i
can tell you in history
you know when japanese came to china
they what they did the horrific war
crime they did
are unspeakable when germany
you know uh nazi went against the
jewish people and the the
the the the roma what they did were as
people crimes
what people do in the middle east over
and over
you know are unspeakable unspeakable
crimes against humanity and i can tell
you so many other examples
i think you know
first you need to vilify someone like
you need to make this propaganda those
are
the words of the world look at those
muslim and
to be honest look at my face
i look like wanted people
everywhere in fbi list so and
my face is not a face that you know
for an american guard who grew up in the
south
who doesn't know about muslims who
doesn't know about arabs doesn't know
about africans
i look like a bad guy as far as he's
because he's or
i'm conditioned and they think they
really think they are doing good thing
by beating me breaking me
yeah okay okay i suppose that's probably
how the nazis
worked too is kind of brainwashed into
thinking they were doing the right thing
did um when you were when you were on
the inside did you have any help
how did you manage to get out so
uh i think you know
writing the book you know i'm the only
detainee
who wrote inside prison and
who get his work out it took a very long
time
you know and i'm not a writer i'm a
technician
i'm a electrical engineer
but i just love to write and so as a
hobby
and i just want to tell my story because
this is a very big
shame like someone who is in prison for
killing people that brings a big shame
on my family michaela believe it or not
and i don't want that i want my family
first and foremost to know
i'm the good guy you taught the good
values of islam
of peace of doing good things of
befriending
people i'm not a guy who is killing
people
and the angry guy and the united states
of america
refused to let my book be published it
took almost eight years
of five now
everywhere i go everywhere
i went i won i went to this hebes corpus
i won my case because the judge told
them
you have no evidence to hold this guy
and uh but they refused to release me
and what is very disheartening
we know now because of record
that in 2005 the united states
government
knows that i was innocent we know that
because we have it now
black and white and they let me ride in
prison
for 11 more years
and this good thing you know the good
thing about this a lot of people tell me
why you don't hate american i don't hate
american because
american by and large are good people
americans stood by me i know in the
thick of torture
some of the guards who smuggle food
and gave it to me under the table you
know girls who bring me
books and one of the girls even who
befriended me with a coffee
and rami you know i i hope you can play
ramy
and then we bonded over it we bonded
over you know like
gossiping about people behind their
backs because
that our sport in this country
we love to gossip about people and
and he visited me twice in mauritania
after my release
and i joke with him steve wood i joke
with him
because you know you know we have
mosquitoes in this country and we have
small nets
to protect you i put a small net in the
living room for him i said this is
yourself
you know now i'm in control you know
and and yeah and it's good
we want to show the world that there is
no war between
between the west and the muslims we want
to show the world
we are brothers and sisters and we need
to cooperate because
without cooperation we cannot survive
because we
all all uh in this
as one team against bad people who try
to
drive a wedge between us
how much um how much did your faith help
when you were when you were uh well
incarcerated for lack of a better word
uh a lot you know like you know i
i went to a koran school
you know it's it's very similar to
catholic school in canada
you know where they are very strict like
regimen
and you know it's it's very good school
actually you know they
teach you you know discipline and so and
i memorized all the quran
you know and i kept singing the quran
all the time
all the time singing and that singing
and that prayer that meditation
helped me a lot and what helped me most
is when i decide i have no anger toward
anyone
and i remember this day vividly michaela
this analyst military analyst came to me
she was a middle-aged woman
she looked at me said why are you so
upbeat
i was like what does a beat mean because
i didn't speak english you know i
learned english from the guards and they
interrogated
wow and she said yeah i beat means
like happy and then i said that okay
you know because you know
you know the biggest punishment of
someone
is committing a crime if you commit a
crime that's
the real punishment for you when i know
in
inside prison that i didn't do anything
wrong to anyone i was happy
because i said at the end of the day i
know i didn't hurt anyone
and i always joke with the girls when
they tell me why are you always smiling
and singing
i tell them because i want my
humiliation to be as
cheap as possible and
they laugh
wow that's incredible wow you're
definitely making me
feel feel a bit bad about being mopey
ever what does that mean
a mopey it just means women like whiny
and sad
i think you are very strong i think you
don't give yourself
credit well thank you thank you very
much
um i'm gonna i'm gonna see
okay can we can we go back can you can
you tell me
so you said the u.s knew that you were
innocent you said from 2005
to 2014 when you got 16
16. end of 11 years
okay okay so how did you manage to get
out
like did you have like uh
lawyers to help like how did you manage
to get out because
i'm sure that if you end up detaining
somebody and they end up being
and torturing them and they end up being
innocent and then they write a book
about it
i'm sure you don't really want to let
that person out
so how did you manage to get back home
i'm glad i'm glad you're so smart to
understand
the so the problem
was like my lawyer put it in the movie
and i urge your audience please to watch
the movie
i'll link it in show notes thank you
thank you so much
michaela is that i became a witness
i became a witness and there is
something like they call
operational operational you know how
they operate
how the whole intelligence world
operates and i know so much about it now
by virtue of going through all of this
and being interrogated by
all agencies including canadian
wow secret service and they didn't want
me out
and they want to stifle me as much as
possible
but when the book came out and so and it
made a lot of splices it became a
bestseller including in canada
including indiana and in germany in
sweden in many countries
and in more than 25
languages and then that was like too
much
and then they made a board a board
or of different us agencies
to decide my faith and they
they agreed unanimously that i'm not a
threat to the united states of america
and they said we don't need to hold him
and they
let go of me but i'm still i'm still
like
not a free man because whenever i apply
for a visa
for any country they look at me
they say he was in guantanamo it means
he was a bad guy
they don't see me as the victim that is
i am
no and i i'm telling this is not a
secret
because now my lawyers in canada they
asking for
a real investigation to go to the bottom
line of what happened to me in canada
and how much did canada help
the united states in my kidnapping and
in my torture because canada is a
country ruled by law
not by it's not a military dictatorship
and if people do mistake it's okay but
they should be held accountable
and i'm i forgive them all i'm asking
for them to clear my name and to know
that i came
to canada in peace because i love canada
and i love canadian people and they
never did me
anything but good things they offered me
a place
to stay and they offer me
you know they welcome me to their
country and if those likes
people pass some wrong intelligence to
the american we should know about that
and they should clear my name
so you released your so your book became
a bestseller while you were still
incarcerated and it kind of led to your
release you think it helped
absolutely you know because i don't know
whether
you heard this saying democracy dies
in darkness so without
journalism without people like you
talking and raising issues there is no
democracy
because that the only way that we can
have democracy is for people to know
what the government is doing
and government is not going to willingly
share with people
what they're doing
yeah i agree
okay okay let's see
how so it got made into this movie it
got made into a movie with
some pretty big actors benedict
cumberbatch
um how how close
is it to what really happened
what you see in the movie is very
accurate but i always say
guantanamo bay is the dramatization of
the mauritanian
because michaela you can now
put 70 days of sleeplessness in a movie
unless you just take an actor and make
him
without sleep 70 days and just watch him
that you cannot do you know because
movie is just like
you know give you a picture but all the
scenes
including that you know guard who cried
you know because i felt really bad for
sergeant sergeant-staff sergeant mary
you know they she i think she's a good
person
at heart and they tell her to sexually
assault me
and when they start beating she was
crying that actually happened
you know in front of me you know
okay
okay well i don't think i've been
speechless very many times in podcasts
but i'm most certainly speechless
um that is that's terrifying
what are you doing now so what are your
goals right now other than
you know trying to figure out what
exactly happened and clear your name
so first i want to tell you that i'm
a happy person you know you look like a
happy person
yes i am a happy person you know at
least i
try to put a brave name my doctor told
you muhammad do you need to deal with
your
psychological problem ptsd and so and
i'm aware of that i'm aware of that
because there are triggers
that makes me when they comes
i get like a catatonic
state you know and
so my main work now you know i'm writing
i have a new book coming out
and it's a very big success ahmed and
zarga it's about
camels if you love do you like camels
i think so i'm seeing them in dubai yeah
you need something
so yes you need to i haven't i haven't
written one yet
no you need to write them you know
they're very safe you know you need
someone need to hold the tether for
everything and if i would i would have
helped you
and i like about this bedouin life it's
a novel
you know and it's thank god it's not
very stressful
it came out in february and
and you will hear more about this work
very soon
and i'm promoting my movie and promoting
my my book
the new edition and i'm working
toward freedom and democracy in my part
of the world
you need to stop like being an exception
we need to join the free world you know
arab countries need to be
real democracies and we need to have the
rule of law
because we deserve it we deserve to be
free
people and i want to travel all the
world
every single country and take picture
put on my instagram and meet people and
sign my book
and i'm like i said that's
those are my dreams
those those sound like pretty good
dreams
i hope that's possible i hope that's
possible
yeah i really do and i'll i'll put links
to
both your books in the show notes so
people can check that out
plus the movie thank you so much and
please
if you could send me the link because i
want to watch
i love your shows you have very
beautiful
instagram stuff it's really good it's
really good
well thank you thank you very much um
okay so i have a few more questions
so i told you one of the things i'm
trying to focus on is how to
become resilient so that when terrible
things happen to you
it doesn't ruin the rest of your life
do you have suggestions for people
who've gone through
a traumatic experience on what they can
do
to not have that experience
ruin the rest of their life
you know we have a saying in quran
you know and i think it's a it's very
close there are very close things in the
bible too
you know if you forgive you get closer
to god you need to forgive not because
the people
that hurt you uh deserve it
or they want it or they even ask about
it but you need to live in peace with
yourself
because you need to free the space in
your head and feel it with the people
you love
and you care about because if you obsess
about someone
they will ruin your life first thing
forgiveness
and second thing like
always when you find yourself in a place
that you don't like
you know it doesn't matter maybe even a
doctor office
you don't like the doctor try to find
the most comfortable space
for and try to feel good
try feeling good is the indicator
you know like me when i get upset
i like to watch comedy because they make
me
feel good you know and try to surround
yourself with the people who love you
and you know mikhail i was so obsessed
with
what people thought about me you know i
was so worried
what to wear how to act
but when i was thrown in that six
by eight feet cell and
the door slammed shut
i know i wasn't that important i knew
the world would go on without me
i'm not that important to the world i'm
only important to myself
and i need to care about myself and the
people who care about
that's why whenever i do something
people come to me
say mohammedu what would people think
about this
i would tell them there are two kinds of
people people who love me
they don't judge me and they accept me
for who i am
and people who don't love me i don't
care about them
absolutely not
okay that's good advice that's good
advice i've been trying to
i was really sick as a kid like very
very ill and i managed to get better
and it's made me very angry at the
medical system because the medical
system didn't help like the medical
system hurt me
and it's made me very angry and i'm
trying really hard to
get rid of the like resentment and
just be thankful that i'm better and try
and replace like whatever anger
resentment i have with love like you
said but it's it's tricky and then there
are situations where it'll pop back
up again and it'll be like so much anger
and i think what you said about
trying to put yourself in situations
that make you feel good
uh i'm starting to tune into that and
that's i think that's really important
it's like oh something about this
situation makes me uncomfortable
maybe that means that situation isn't
good for me
to try and go somewhere where you're
more comfortable
which is something i ignored for a long
time right just brushed off as
unimportant but that's
that's very valuable advice i'm sorry to
hear that
absolutely and it's real this is
this is real ptsd it's real and it's not
something you can just brush
off and you need to deal with it just
like you said
you know and and
it's real it's real
um and let me know if they're if you
don't want to discuss anything but
are there are for triggers you have
do you just avoid them all together like
is that how you're
you're living at the moment so
there is no nothing off limit for you
to ask me now or in
future i think or in a private
discussion
the trigger that i have if some if i
feel
threatened by someone okay okay
or if if encounter with the authorities
when i go to airport or something i get
sweary
when i hear the airplane taken off and
you know and landing that's really makes
me very nervous
and very upset because for 20 years
20 years all the planes that took me
were
for evil thing and i never wanted to
board the plane
okay well that makes sense um
do you think do you think with exposure
like
with positive experiences maybe with you
know
tour or book interviews do you think
that's something that you could
eventually get past yes
i believe in therapy and actually
actually again i will say this canadians
are
very very good with
with with this kind of therapy
because i saw two studies
made by canadian so people are afraid of
let's say snake
so they take you little bit by little
bit you know
and there is also this canadian of
middle eastern descent
who take people who went through
traumatic like accident and then he
replayed the accident
but in a setting that is comfortable to
them
so to try try to replace the bad memory
with good memories so
and that makes sense to me and by the
way
i'm coming to dubai too so
that's oh you are yeah i'm planning to
go there in in summer in late summer
because there is this one i don't know
whether you know about this
expo 2020 i've heard about it i'm not
going to be here but
i kind of want to come back it sounds
incredible yeah it's big it's the
biggest like
every i think 10 years or something and
uh
i i'm helping the the mauritanian stand
so to promote the mauritanian stand
oh wow when is it maybe i could come
back
yeah yeah absolutely you should come
back it's between october
okay 21 and uh for six months
i think end
[Music]
march yes for six months oh
i had no idea okay well that sounds
interesting
yeah actually i always love to see dubai
because everybody tells me dubai is
beautiful
everybody tells me that i know have you
been
never never it's
it's okay so i saw pictures from
the year 2000 and pictures from 2020
it's insane how much they've built here
like
the buildings are massive everything is
like shiny and new
i've never been in a city that was this
well realistically that had this much
money right it's
it's crazy what they've built like and
yeah the water is beautiful
it's it's it's amazing here it seems
kind of like a
it's almost like a theme park like
everything's so big it doesn't seem real
i feel like i came from a small town in
in canada
and i'm i'm in the biggest city in
canada but it feels like it was a small
town compared to here
what city are you from toronto
ah okay yeah toronto is is a big city
and you guys have those
very big streets like i never seen a
street
i was in montreal number 3570 what kind
of street is that
because the longest street in germany is
like 130 or something
yeah canada is is big yes
very big uh yeah
i was in i went to university in
montreal
wow uh 99 where were you in 99
i was in toronto in in in 99. and in
2000 i was between 99 and 2000 in
in montreal
okay muhammadu do i have any other
questions for you
i feel like i need to get more i i feel
like i need to get um
more advice do you get
do you ever get angry about what's
happened to you
and if so i think you already answered
this but how do you calm down
uh you know one of the things that you
may not know about me
that a canadian academy
after my release contacted me you know
a coaching uh canadian academy of
coaching
and i said that i qualified for a
scholarship
and i took the scholarship and i i
i graduated as a canadian international
coach
you know i'm i also help people going
through hard
times and so you do yes i do
and so of course i get upset you know
i get upset especially you know what
upsets me
when people don't recognize their
mistakes
you know when people say i did what i do
and then i'm i don't apologize
you know that upsets me you know a lot
but in a way it makes me laugh
and this laugh that it's a little bit
evil i'm telling you because
i feel that they're not in peace with
themselves
i mean i have guards calling me and
apologizing
and saying we want to make peace and i
have them on
social media and they're my friends and
i say of course i forgive you
no question asked and we are friends and
we laugh
and we talk about stuff but the people
who say
to me we don't care about you and
and we we don't you know they are very
upset and very angry and i just keep
laughing because
i see that they're suffering really
they're
really suffering because they don't want
to
pass you know to move on
it's amazing thing it's an amazing thing
yeah that's interesting that's
interesting
okay let me think
so that's angry yeah well is there
anything else you want to tell me about
before we go
all i want to tell you is that i'm so
grateful
for you inviting me to your program and
allowing me
to talk on your platform and share my
experience
with you and i'm so glad and
i'm very grateful for this opportunity
well muhammadu like thank you so much
for coming on
i couldn't pass up the opportunity
because
it's very rare that you see somebody
who's gone through such hard times who's
put himself back together and is trying
to help other people
and so i thought that was definitely
something worth sharing
um i will link your books below and the
movie
and i would encourage people to check it
out
but thank you very very much for coming
on
you're a very brave person
thank you michaela and i hope i
pronounce your name correctly
you did i hope i pronounced your name
correctly too thank you
thank you so much
[Music]
you